that's what's wrong with democratic
socialism that's what's wrong with black
lives matter with antifa and with the me
too movement it's
it's based on so wanting a specific
person or group to be wrong that we will
do
anything we can almost taste it
mug clubs for closers this is what i
want to talk with you about uh
today you know a lot of times people are
looking for something i'm a 30
31 year old guy who gives a crap what i
have to say as far as life advice but it
matters to some of you so
this is something that actually uh was
on my heart this week because i was
watching
my favorite movie ever so all this me
too the black lives matter the
democratic socialism
it all spawns from the same evil it all
comes from this idea of shifting the
balance of power simply for the sake
of shifting the balance of powers the
foundational philosophy of the left we
all know we've talked about it this sort
of underdog theory
it's known by another word envy
so one of my favorite films is is the
edge uh
have you seen i have not i have not i
want to though i watch the trailer
you keep talking about i want to watch
it it is as a matter of fact you know
let me say the reason why is because it
is my favorite film it is not
maybe it is my favorite film period i'll
say that people give me crap about that
all the time but go go and watch the
film
comment here let me know what you think
whenever i talk with someone about this
film i'm like
that's your favorite shouldn't it be
godfather shouldn't it but i think
chinatown was a better film by the way
uh who cares about the quaaludes in the
14 year old it was a good film
but the edge is my favorite film
everyone comes back and says
yeah it was pretty good no one comes
back and says no i thought it sucked
so this is one of those ideas we're
conditioned to not like films i get it
there are a couple
couple of lines in the film that might
be cheesy there are a couple of green
screen sequences that maybe don't hold
up today
but i think it's at least the most
underrated film of the last quarter
century
and i just found out that the writer
david mamet is going to be on
the same writer of glengarry glen ross
who he wrote the edge the untouchables
uh is it i don't know he wrote a
most prolific stage right of our
generation he's written a lot of great
films he's going to be on the show
i cannot tell you how excited i am he
actually
came out of the closet as a conservative
with an article titled
i believe it was i don't have it in
front of me why i'm no longer a brain
dead liberal
new york times i believe is where i
wrote it that's funny i could be wrong
someone who's new york magazine but
i don't know exactly where it was so
someone could maybe let me know i don't
have a source for this i didn't prep for
this but
it's like i just was my mouth was
getting dry so i had a drink and that's
awkward for people who are listening
on audio by the way subscribe on itunes
if you aren't for when you're on the
road
um here's the thing he wrote the edge
long before the article where he came
out
as a conservative and this is a big
reason i love the film
but there are tons of reasons to love
the film especially when you re-watch it
it's one of those it's like a video game
where you backtrack and there are easter
eggs nearly every single shot almost
every line of dialogue means something
but something that is singularly unique
about this film the billionaire
played by anthony hopkins the
character's name is charles morse
kind of a spoiler alert here three two
good the billionaire is actually the
good guy
and this relates back to the point i'll
be making in the realm of cinema where
the wealthy person is nearly always the
big evil
oil baron or the corrupt wall street
banker here's this film
where charles morse the billionaire
surrounded by artists photographers and
even minorities by the way one of whom
just gets the crap of
him mulled out of a bear way worse than
the revenant scene uh
the standout man of character the true
blue character
is the old white guy patriarchy
personified charles moore throughout the
film he not only improves people's lives
but he saves them
and the point is that sometimes shifting
the balance of power
merely for the sake of it doesn't take
into account who's going to get the
power
once the shift is completed sure some of
the worst people throughout history were
powerful
so we're all of the best and if we try
to strip power from people simply
because we perceive them to hold it
as we're talking about now and these
articles you see them with
with me too that's the end game with
democratic socialism so if you want to
strip power just just because people
have it that's the
that's the reason well who's going to
maintain the balance of power afterward
hillary clinton the metoo charlatans the
lgbtq aip movement
feminists well just because they aren't
charles morse
something else on the edge that really
stands out to me
is everyone in the film wants something
from this billionaire
at every turn he doesn't know who to
trust he doesn't know their motives it's
incredibly isolating i really highly
recommend this film and
there are a lot of undertones here that
i could get into hopefully i will with
david
when it's on the show but it's really
easy to vilify people of power
or perceived wealth you know why it's
easy
because it's a lot harder to look
ourselves in the mirror for the selfish
pieces of garbage that we all
are when we want something from those
people well i don't know it could be
cheaper deodorant while we all vilify
walmart could be cheaper gas when we
vilify oil companies or
safer streets while we vilify cops
you know i i've known a few wealthy
people in my life i've been fortunate
enough to know a few wealthy
people uh no i am not i am not amongst
them
but i've seen him happy with him happy
i've seen it happen with them
uh people like um i don't wanna you know
okay
mark carey kevin uh
all people i've seen with folks tugging
at their sleeve demanding something of
them
you know what happens when these people
don't get what they want
who's a rich jerk and that's how the
shift of power
just for the sake of it begins it
sprouts from the seed of selfishness
i know people say where are you going
because all of us do this
the difference is it's a foundational
principle of the teaching of the modern
left
to use an example kevin this is a real
person
uh an incredibly wealthy i'd like to i
feel fortunate to say a friend of mine
i'm always uncomfortable asking him for
anything even though he's offered a lot
you know this guy um to give you an idea
okay let me let me do some examples here
i'm trying
i'm trying to make sure they don't
reveal identity i don't really think
they care
let me let me give you two examples
there are two videos completed here
louder with crowder this team never
would have been able to do
if not for this man kevin lending us his
personal plane
i know it sounds people oh white white
people problems
listen yeah the guy has a plane good for
him
but you know why he lent it to us just
to be a blessing
just to be a blessing not not only to us
but to you the fans
one of them was a crowder confronts one
of them was the whole yaf conference and
why because we
there was no way to get out there
commercially and they were they were
over 800 fans and that in that uh
not meso ballroom i wouldn't be able to
see he knew that we needed to get six
crew
members out to a location we couldn't
afford to do it in time otherwise we
wouldn't have been able to
it was an unbelievable blessing that he
here
and if you don't ask for it with a lot
of these people you'll be surprised as
to how generous they are
it applies to every moment of your life
really this is how we tie it back to you
think of anyone you've ever
really been mad with your dad your
teacher maybe your boss
your mom all people who at those moments
in time were in a position of authority
over you it comes down to submitting to
authority
sometimes when appropriate the left
wants you to submit to authority when
it's the right people based on identity
politics
not based on morality whereas yep as a
christian
i do believe there's a biblical basis
for submitting to authority
when appropriate so all these people
almost all the people you've probably
disliked at some moment in your life had
authority over you now think of anyone
on the flip side who's ever actually
really helped you and been there
when you needed it someone who actually
meant it we hear it's all i got your
back bro
what does that mean what does that mean
someone who truly meant it when they
said they had your back
could it have been maybe your dad
maybe that teacher maybe that boss
maybe your mom now magnify that that's
just a wealthy person that's just a big
name actor that's just a person in some
kind of position of authority
who for some reason you or i or society
doesn't like
and because of that we automatically
assume them to be in the wrong
why because we so want them to be in the
wrong
that's what's that's what's wrong with
democratic socialism that's what's wrong
with black lives matter with antifa and
with the metoo movement it's
it's based on so wanting a specific
person or group to be wrong that we will
do
anything we can almost taste it
and that's the foundation of the left
today the point here is is really
there's nothing easier than to vilify
people
in positions of power or authority or
success that we haven't achieved
because we haven't achieved it it's
easier to just hate the people who have
some of them are bad people of course
but it's even harder to look yourself in
the mirror and be honest as to why you
hate that person is it them
is it the idea of them or is it you so
think of this in your life if you're
listening right now is there someone
under who's authority maybe you've been
maybe even difficult maybe you've been
given a hard time maybe even vilifying
them maybe you're envious of them
and you don't treat them so well really
right now
i'm going to give you a second i want
you to think of one person this is an
exercise
pick one person in your life
you think that person deserves how you
treat them you think that person maybe
has his or her own crap to deal with
you think maybe that person could use
someone to really trust
maybe it's a person with a plane point
is it doesn't matter
you've been thinking of you and we all
do this make it right
go today right now make it right or or
at least at least make it right moving
forward
starting today because the truth is
there are just as many powerless ass
as there are powerful heroes and vice
versa it's human nature
i'm not trying to shift the balance of
power just for the sake of it
i don't want to restructure society
based on envy
all i want to see are more good guys and
girls at the top so you know what
the left wants you to be that guy don't
be that guy hey if you like this video
subscribe or click the notification bell
right next to the subscription button
because subscribing doesn't mean
anything anymore
now according to the youtube gods and uh
if you like the late night show you can
watch it every single day a full hour
at lotto with credit.com mug club
subscribe there
that way we aren't beholden to the evil
youtube overlords and we don't have to
start playing video games with
mouth sound effects or
children react